so with the masters in full swing this
weekend it is a sign that spring and
golf
is finally here alex yeah las vegas of
course brings in golf lovers from all
over the place to enjoy our many
beautiful courses and driving ranges
and one of those is topgolf katie stood
live there this morning
with more hey kate it's great to have
you
[Music]
yes it's great to be here now i am going
to
be swinging one of these clubs
momentarily i do want to preface this by
saying it's been well over
a year since i've done this but we have
lindsey hoskins here who is the director
of instruction
for topgolf and she's going to give us
some key pointers
for you to up your game now lindsay take
it away
okay awesome so what i like to start
with with a lot of students is just the
fundamentals
so our grip and our setup so grip is
definitely really important to get that
ball go nice and straight
so for us right-handed golfers our left
hand is going to be on the top of the
club
we want to be able to see pointer finger
knuckle middle finger knuckles so if we
roll that hand in we can see those two
knuckles thumb right down the middle
and then we're going to go ahead and put
that right hand underneath that left
hand is right-handed golfer once again
vice versa for left-handed golfer so
that's going to be our grip
and then set up's really important so
for a majority of our shots we can go
feet about shoulder width apart
we're going to bend a little bit from
the waist flex those knees and then
weight goes in the balls of those feet
not in those heels
okay wonderful so now i'm going to pass
the mic off to lindsay
she's going to critique my form lindsay
here you go let's do this
all right you got this
so lindsay walk me through one more time
we got the grip here we're showing the
knuckles
yep good and the stance
and yeah you got to watch that ball
so keep an eye on the ball make that
good l shape that we worked on earlier
sweep that tee okay
yeah great shot not too shabby
good job thank you so much honestly i'm
impressed with myself that this is all
because of lindsay's
fantastic instruction and what's great
about topgolf is that
you know you don't have to be an expert
to come here and you can get these
lessons just go to topgolf.com
las vegas to make any sort of
reservation that you might need to
watch the masters this weekend yeah
thank you so much lindsay
reporting live from topgolf this morning
kate houston 8 news now houston
that was a great swing yeah good job
it's on the fairway at least goodness
that was awesome
fantastic masters better watch out all
right
thanks kate have fun up there it looks
beautiful